elite dangerous is a game that's about
there's combat in it so it can be a
combat game if that's what you want out
of it but it's also a space exploration
game it's about trading it's about
building up this economy it's about you
can go out and you know pick up these
bounty quests you can assassinate people
and it's much more I don't know if
nuanced is the right word but it's much
more layered than just combat and I
actually got to play it with an oculus
rift and that game is complex and I was
like nervously
kind of like shaking at the thought of
undocking from the space station and
getting through the space Hawk alive
with this crazy SciTech x52 joystick rig
I was using with a million buttons that
I couldn't see because I had an oculus
rift on my face yeah an oculus rift adds
so much immersion because you're in this
cockpit and if you're in a dogfight
instead of relying on a little mini map
on the screen here you can actually like
glance upward and behind you and see
that there's an enemy this way so you've
kind of got to flip around and go after
like that
thorngate well it's a a team over from
it's been published by EA and I actually
had a quite a long conversation with the
lead developer on the game
they're obviously wanting to get into
that space but they're trying to make a
game that's you know to the existing
MOBA existing mobile stuff something's
gonna appeal to them in a different way
ie it's more accessible it's looking
interesting an accessible MOBA we'll see
I own is free-to-play so you know at
least you just go try it right as good
is good yeah we saw that battle cry
trailer a couple of weeks ago looks all
pretty and stuff Viktor Antonov from
half-life 2 Fame it's cool it's like a
big old collaboration between a bunch of
real tons of people it's free-to-play so
this hoist that and which I don't know
kind of always has a sustain or whatever
game is coming out but it kind of looks
like imagine if team fortress was third
person and had like only melee combat
because they've outlawed gunpowder in
this world they have a playable on the
show floor but it's it's it's pretty
early days but yeah it looks like
something to look out for if only for
the fact that the people were involved
in that game have a lot of big games
behind them so kind of trusting to do
right yes we have to see one of the
developers of hotline Miami make a level
on the fly I'm on number two it's super
easy it's almost like Mario maker in
that regard works just like he laid out
in a couple of boxes which became you
know rooms eventually put doors and
dropped in furniture and refrigerators
and stuff and then put down people and
then in like a snap he could jump down
into these level and start playing and
then oh that wasn't good so he zoom back
out and he tweaked it around it I mean
it looks super simple and the reason
they're putting it in hotline Miami 2
was this is the last ever hotline Miami
they want the commuter to be able to do
whatever they want going forward I've
got a chance to play gray goo which had
me very excited because I'd seen that
GDC and it made an impression then and
it it made an impression this time as
well it's a strategy title coming from
petroglyph you know they've made
starwars Empire at war universe at war
and this game is in the same thing but
what makes it interesting is one of the
factions is the grey goo and if you know
science fiction then you know that the
grey goo is basically nano nano BOTS
that just take over and turn everything
into just one giant much so in the grey
goo is essentially a faction in which
you don't have a base and everything
starts with this big glob of goo that
you can command around to collect
resources and then eventually split it
off into more types of goo that in and
of themselves can turn into different
types of units so if you're into rushing
or if you're into just getting into play
right away and staying on the offensive
this the gray goo faction is the way to
go there are two other factions as
wealth of data and the humans but I only
played the gray goo today and I'm glad I
did because it was pretty unique litsen
bound age is this game I think I think
the reason why it exists is actually
maybe one of the most endearing things
about this guy Michael macmaine used to
work in like software and this I don't
think he wants me to tell me he wants me
to tell you exactly where he had a
company that made software which
probably made them a lot of money and
they basically took all the engineers to
work on that stuff got a lot of game dev
dudes and he's a big like RPG fans only
ever you only ever plays mage so he
basically took all these dudes in his
company and all these game developers
went I want to make the [ __ ] game
where mages are just ope and that's this
environment it is literally a game where
you are a nay
who has zero cooldown it uses CryEngine
to look friggin gorgeous but every soon
and it's like well like a village them
is it's just the only reason that game
exists is that a bunch of people love
mages like he loves mages he's got the
money to make game room ages people on
the internet like majors they're into it
so it's like this just this big like
orgy of people with massive major
hard-ons I love it so I got to play some
dreadnought which is a game coming from
Jaeger the people that made spec ops the
line and it's a free to play space
action game a multiplayer game and what
makes it a little bit different from
most space combat games is getting
control giant ships you know that's
where the name dreadnought comes from
you're not rushing through space in a
strike freezer you're taking things slow
and steady and a giant battleship type
of type of situation and it was really
fun you get different different skills
that you can use different types of
ships there is a Corvette and support
ships and also giant battleships and of
course the dreadnought which is in the
title of the game and it was a lot of
fun we actually played two team death
matches and I got crushed the first time
we won the second so it was just super
super good something more than I was
expecting I saw I saw The Sims 4 which
is bizarre if I would describe it in one
word so it's basically about fleshing
out the characters of the Sims and their
personality traits but it seems to
manifest itself is very kind of quirky
in eccentric ways so like they started
the demo and there was this man Sam who
had gotten to a heated altercation
earlier in the day and he just couldn't
let it go and is just the anger was
boiling up inside him and because he had
the bro personality traits he decided to
work off his anger by doing rage sit ups
so here he is in this public park
working off the anger by doing sit-ups
and just grunting and shouting to
himself and that was like the first
minute of a 30 minute demo one of the
games that I saw here at e3 2014
as h1z1 it is Sony Online
Entertainment's sort of Daisy clone I
guess they're sort of they're trying to
distance themselves from Daisy a bit by
having crafting elements in the game but
it feels you know and it also runs on
the planetside 2 engine so it definitely
looks a lot better than Daisy
so it's shaping up pretty good you can
drive vehicles you can go scavenge and
find guns shoot other players chocolate
on trees build houses perma death is
still a thing they mentioned potentially
clams at some point in the future so I
got to say one of my favorite PC games
was actually hex shards of fate and it's
super super complex and I don't know
that I understood every little detail
that was described while I watched but
some of the things that are really
interesting about it is it's sort of a
combination of an MMO and a trading card
game and one of the things that you can
do in hex is do raids with other people
and what that involves is basically you
and several other players against us
like a single AI boss and that whole
idea sounds really cool I mean it has
that kind of thing has been done before
but it seems like the MMO part of this
game is gonna be really important it's
gonna have this you know big
single-player campaign in which you will
actually deal with cards that you don't
get anywhere else and art that you don't
see anywhere else so it's all of the
trading card games in one plus it's got
got these really interesting things
where cards will actually morph
depending on certain circumstances so
you might have a card that represents an
imprisoned person and then that and then
based in certain circumstances you might
free that prisoner and then it becomes a
liberated person and so the card
actually changes depending on
circumstances in-game and that kind of
stuff just really intrigues me it looks
super super complex
you can even slot in gems into cards to
make one individual card very very
different from other people's version of
that
giving it giving it attributes all its
own so all in all I've got to say I'm
really intrigued by hex shards of fate
and while I I suspect it might be a
little over my head I'm really looking
forward to trying it out